So we write the program as a truly parallel program, or in other words,
the application programmer is going to think
about his application and write the program as
an explicitly parallel program. And there are
two styles of writing explicitly parallel programs. And
correspondingly, system support for those two tiles
of explicitly pavalled programs. One is called message
passing style of explicitly pavalled program. The
run time system is going to provide a message
passing laterally which has primitives for. An
application thread to do sends and receives to
its peers that are executing on other
nodes of the cluster. So this message passing
style of explicitly parallel program is true to
the physical nature of the cluster. The physical
nature of the cluster is the fact that
every processor has its private memory. And this memory
is not shared across all the processors. So
the only way a processor can communicate with, another
processor is by sending a message through the
network that this processor can receive. This processor cannot
directly reach into the memory of this processor. Because
that is not the way a cluster is architected.
So, the messaging passing library is true
to the physical nature of the cluster. That
there is no physically shared memory. And
lots of examples of message passing libraries that
have been written to support explicit parallel
programming. In a cluster they include MPI, message
passing interface, MPI for short, PVM, CLF
from digital equipment corporations. So these are all
examples of message passing libraries that have been built with the intent of
allowing application programmer to write explicitly parallel
programs using this message passing style. And
to this day, many scientific applications
running on large scale clusters in national
labs like Lawrence Livermore, and Argonne National
Labs and so on, use this style
of programming using MPI as the message
passing fabric. Now, the only downside to the
message-passing style of programming is that it is
difficult to program using this style. If you're
a programmer who's written sequential programs, the transitions
paths to writing an explicitly parallel program is
easier if there is this. Notion of shared
memory, because it is natural to think of
shared data structures among different threads of
an application. And that's the reason making the
transition from sequential program to parallel programming, using
for instance the P thread library or SMP
is fairly intuitive and easy pathway. On
the other hand, If the programmer has to
think in terms of coordinating the activities on
different processes by explicitly descending and desisting messages
from their peers. That is calling for a failuratical change
of thinking in terms of how to structure a program.